il est le fruit de cette plante rampante
le cornichon dont les français raffolent
dans ce champ de 11 hectares la récolte
a démarré début juillet 45 ramasseurs
polonais sont à l'oeuvre pour cueillir
ce condiment
c'est un produit frais sans herbicides
sans insecticide qu'en cassant deux on
entend du bruit quand on croque sacre
aussi bien ici la récolte se fait
exclusivement à la main les plans sont
fragiles et doivent être manipulées avec
délicatesse
tous les cornichons ne sont pas à
ramasser les plus gros sont cueillies
pour soulager la plante mais pas
conservé ça va toujours mal au poignet
mois la première consigne conad coeur
c'est la taille de cornichons pas du
mini mini extra-fins pas des très gros
mais des cornichons qu'ils soient
correctes à mettre dans le bocal se
soient pas des jumeaux ou se soient pas
des tordus mais sa vente ou l'esthétique
c'est important d'avoir des bocages
plusieurs dizaines de petites mains dans
les champs et le même nombre à la ferme
pour mener à bien le conditionnement les
cornichons sont triées par taille
puis ils sont bichonnés sélectionnés sur
ce tapis roulant prononcez pas comparer
bien sûr
en fait maintenant on trouvait là depuis
dix jours les cornichons sont ensuite
mises en beaucoup dans ce laboratoire
flambant neuf
toute la ligne et automatiser un
investissement indispensable pour le
développement de l'entreprise a dû
s'adapter
à la demande mais tout en gardant la
qualité du bord du son on a adapté la
machine à notre tête avant le
conditionnement est adapté où il y avait
deux lignes n'étaient 19 personnes
au jour d'aujourd'hui on est prêt puis
personnes vont faire tourner la ligue en
bout de ligne 350 milles peau sortent
chaque année ils sont vendus dans le
monde entier
certains se retrouve même sur les tables
de l'elysée